use la ley conmutativa de la
multiplicación para escribir 2 por 34 de
diferente manera simplifica ambas
expresiones para mostrar que tienen
idénticos resultados nuevamente esta ley
conmutativa nos dice que el orden no
importa por lo que podemos escribir este
2 por 34
y va a ser lo mismo que escribir 34 por
2 el orden no va a importar ya que ambos
van a arrojar el mismo resultado vamos a
resolverlo aunque es poco probable que
vean a escrita una multiplicación así en
este caso la multiplicación es 2 por 34
es muy difícil que ustedes se encuentren
en una multiplicación desarrollada de
esta manera normalmente las personas
ponen arriba el número que tiene más
dígitos y abajo el que tiene menos pero
bueno vamos a resolverlo así
tenemos entonces 4 x 2 es 8
ahora pasamos a las decenas tres por dos
y seis aquí agregamos un cero o podemos
decir que treinta por 260 tenemos esto
lo sumamos y el resultado nos va a dar
ahora vamos a resolver esta otra
multiplicación que es la misma pero con
los números invertidos aquí vamos a
escribir entonces 34
2 y esta es la forma más común de
escribir la multiplicación vamos a
hacerlo 2 por 48 2 por 3 668 como pueden
ver esta es la razón por la que las
personas escriben las cantidades que
tienen más dígitos arriba en lugar de
escribirlas aquí abajo nos ahorramos
algunas líneas no importa si tenemos dos
grupos de 34 o 34 grupos de dos siempre
tendremos como resultado el 68